tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
assemblée nationale georges marchais
propose un contre budget un nouvel
immortel sous la coupole
alain peyrefitte valéry giscard
d'estaing et l'écologie un programme en
neuf points pour une meilleure qualité
de la vie aéronautique française
nos exportations ont doublé en un an
grâce à l'airbus et aux avions marcel
dassault harlequins et le piccolo teatro
lyon à l'odéon on soir ce ne fut pas une
journée sans politique j'aime autant
vous le dire mais entre les auteurs du
budget et les grandes heures de
l'académie on ne savait plus très bien
cet après midi où était le centre
d'intérêt les discours l'assemblée
nationale était académique ceux de
l'académie française rassembler le monde
politique ça a pu provoquer des
agacements d'ailleurs tenez je vous
propose tout de suite d'écoutés ce qu'a
dit michel debré qui pourtant prenait la
parole cet après-midi pour d'abord
approuver la politique de raymond barre
en vous observant avec monsieur le
secrétaire d'état seul sur ses bancs je
me rapproche en oublie peut-être
aurait-il fallu il y a dix huit ans
prévoir qu'un article du règlement
invite l'assemblée à suspendre ces
séances quand l'académie reçoit vous le
voyez michel debré tout de même déçu
quand il s'adresse à robert boulin
puisque le premier ministre de l'ex
ministre de l'économie et des finances
était à ce moment là à la réception
d'alain peyrefitte avec emi française
michel debré regrettait de n'avoir en
face de lui que le ministre de service
comme il a dit tout le gouvernement
était chez les immortels et pas mal de
députés aussi cela dit il ne faut pas
trop se contrarier de ce qu'à la
deuxième journée de la discussion du
budget
et il y est eu un transfert d'intérêt du
ballet du palais bourbon à la coupole à
l'exception des interventions de georges
marchais et de michel debré il y avait
quelque chose de bien tristounet dans ce
débat et à linverse à l'académie
française le beau monde et les habits
verts la parra qui peut paraître
toujours un peu excessif ne devrait pas
nous empêcher de s'élever l'intelligence
et la subtilité et il en a fallu alain
peyrefitte désormais benjamin de l'es4
de l'académie française pour prononcer
l'éloge de paul morand son prédécesseur
le gaulliste alain peyrefitte essayait
de comprendre pourquoi l'écrivain paul
morand resta fidèle au maréchal pétain
et il faut quand même retenir cette
conclusion d'alain peyrefitte qui vaut
pour l'académie française est un peu
moins tout de même pour l'assemblée
nationale
si souvent nous avons succombé à la
tentation de prolonger sans fin aux
épreuves par des ressentiments et de
faire rebondir éternellement nos guerres
civiles toujours depuis trois cent
quarante deux ans l'académie a constitué
une école de tolérance notamment au
lendemain des grandes stratégies
tragédie nationale
puisse notre pays sans cesse menacée par
l'esprit de discorde s'inspirer de cet
hôte le son se souvenir que
l'acceptation de la différence est le
levain de toute société ouverte de toute
société avancée maintenant il nous faut
revenir l'assemblée nationale où
l'événement cet après midi a été la
présentation par georges marchais d'un
contre projet de budget ce qui pourrait
être dans son esprit le budget du
changement en 78 mais il faut remarquer
qu'il est basé sur un programme commun
actualisé par les propositions
communistes et on sait que là dessus les
autres partenaires de la gauche ne sont
pas d'accord c'est exactement le noeud
de la crise à gauche
après georges marchais vous entendrez
les autres orateurs de cet après midi si
nous participions gouvernement du pays
nous proposerions à budget comportant
les moyens de sortir notre peuple de la
misère et notre pays de la crise ce
budget il serait bien sûr totalement
différent de sa vie
nous a présenté hier le premier ministre
ce ne serait pas un budget d'aggravation
de l'austérité ce serait un budget de
progrès social un budget de relance
économique et de l'emploi
un budget d'indépendance nationale
en bref ce serait le budget du
changement lorsque nous évoquons la
possibilité d'un tel budget nous ne nous
payons pas de mots nous ne faisons pas
de promesses vagues ce projet de budget
avec des amis du groupe communiste nous
l'avons élaboré de manière précise
nous avons chiffré aussi bien les
nombreuses propositions qu'il contient
que les et qui vivent ensemble sur
lesquelles il repose ce la première fois
d'ailleurs dans l'histoire du pays qu'un
parti d'opposition se livre à un tel
effort constructif je pense que tout le
monde s'en félicitera le présent budget
tel qu'il est n'alourdit pas l'héritage
financiers c'est ce dont vous pouvez
vous féliciter mais elle est encore
longue
la voie de l'assainissement du
redressement et du rayonnement pour que
soit choisi la voie de l'effort national
j'ai souvent de cette tribune lancé un
appel monsieur le ministre délégué la
tradition de ce au nom desquels je
m'exprime ce soir et de bientôt sur les
bancs de cette assemblée est d'accepter
et ce même de souhaiter que la france
suive cette voie
je veux dire cette voie de l'effort
accompagné par la solidarité comme elle
le fit au lendemain de l'invasion comme
elles recommencent à ben le faire il y à
bientôt 20 ans malgré ces
d'apparence nous savons et vous savez
que dans cette enceinte compte d'abord
et la voici tel difficile la prospérité
public le bien public
le salut public quant à nous nos
propositions sont connus nous ne
reculons pas devant les réformes
structurelles nécessaires pour que notre
pays sorte de sage clés rouge et se
prépare à entrer dans le 21e siècle
comme un grand pays moderne apte à tenir
sa place dans un monde où les échanges
sont et doivent rester ouvert un stand
fiscal réforme de la législation sociale
extension du secteur public
planification démocratique politiques
industrielles figurent parmi les points
forts du programme commun du
gouvernement de la gauche du mans
actualisé que les socialistes proposent
pour français pour sortir le pays de la
crise
autrement que par l'incantation et le
maintien des privilèges
je déclarerais que ce budget nous
apparaît comme un budget réaliste
honnête et sage il est réaliste sur le
plan économique il est honnête sur le
plan social il est sage
sur le plan politique c'est loges
globale que je vais avoir l'honneur au
nom de mon groupe
d'expliciter ne devra pas m'empêcher de
dire sur un certain nombre de points
qu'elle réserve ou même qu'elle critique
me paraissent devoir est exprimée je
m'étonne
non par souci partisans mais dans un
souci d'unité nationale que nos
collègues de l'opposition ne parviennent
pas à reconnaître cette vérité
d'évidence que les difficultés que
connaît la france depuis quatre ans ne
lui sont pas particulière qu'elles ne
sont pas la conséquence de l'impéritie
d'un gouvernement insensible à l'intérêt
dé travail
coeur mais qu'elles sont tout simplement
les conséquences sur notre nation
une crise mondiale voilà donc sous la
coupole de l'académie française pendant
ce temps quai conti cet après midi le
président de la république le premier
ministre et une grande partie du monde
politique ont assisté à la réception
d'alain peyrefitte ministre de la
justice
il y avait là 400 invités parmi eux
madame peyrefitte et puis aussi madame
augustine peyrefitte la mère du ministre
1 ce qui était qui devait se souvenir du
temps où institutrice à nérac l apprenez
à lire à son fils voici l'arrivée du
président de la république patrice de
carolis maintenant sur cette réception
une fois de plus sous la coupole en or a
évoqué deux destinées on aura entendu
deux discours extrêmement brillant dans
son remerciement alain peyrefitte fit
l'éloge de son prédécesseur paul morand
il devait en 55 minutes résumé une
oeuvre de 80 volumes ce qui en soi est
déjà remarquable
après cette évocation claudel et claude
lévi strauss répondit au garde des
sceaux
il salua et l'homme politique est
l'homme de lettres écrivain alain
peyrefitte le fus des 46 avec son
premier ouvrage rue d'une qui sera
rééditée en 1964 avec une préface de
georges pompidou
en 1947 il écrit les roseaux froisser le
mythe de pénélope
il est déjà considéré comme un vrai
moraliste l'académie française couronne
aujourd'hui l'ascension l'auteur de
quand la chine s'éveillera et du mal
français
elle couronne également sans le vouloir
l'homme politique celui qui fut de 1962
à nos jours
huit fois ministre en conclusion de son
discours claude lévi strauss déclaré à
son nouveau confrère vous êtes entré à
l'école normale supérieure à 19 ans est
relativement encore plus jeune que vous
entrez l'académie puisque vous en est le
benjamin être le benjamin c'est chez
alain peyrefitte une habitude il la
conserve rats désormais en devenant
selon la tradition immortel
maintenant il faut faire un retour à la
politique juste pour dire que raymond
barre a confirmé aujourd'hui
officiellement sa candidature aux
élections législatives de 78 dans la 4e
circonscription du rhône à lyon
soyez assurés écrit-il au sénateur maire
de lyon monsieur francisque collomb
soyez assurés que sans rien négliger de
mes responsabilités nationales actuelles
je m'efforcerai de contribuer au
développement de la ville et de servir
le bien-être de ses habitants
demain on devrait voir dans le figaro
dans le cadre du sondage mensuel de la
sofres jeudi on devrait on verra on
verra une montées intéressantes dans les
sondages de raymond barre et une plus
forte monte encore de monsieur giscard
d'estaing pourtant claude estier dans
l'hebdomadaire socialiste l'unité estime
que si l'on en croit les derniers
sondages la majorité n'a nullement
bénéficié jusqu'ici des difficultés de
la gauche et demeure minoritaire dans
les intentions de vote
voyez polémique sur les sondages tout le
monde a été est ou sera écologistes
ce n'est pas un domaine réservé à des
groupes qui s'en servent comme un
tremplin politique ou à ceux qui écoeuré
par la ville ont fait le retour à la
terre pour un temps ou pour longtemps
l'écologie c'est l' affaire de tous un
sujet d'entente pour tous les français
la qualité de la vie est une
revendication unanime disait ce matin
monsieur giscard d'estaing en présentant
la réunion de travail
dunand président pardon la réunion de
travail d'une centaine de représentants
d'associations du cadre de vie et du
haut comité de l'environnement et le
président de la république faisait
remarquer qu'il y avait des exclus de la
qualité de la vie comme il ya des exclus
du progrès et de la croissance
il faut combattre ces inégalités là
aussi disait-il
le président a annoncé un programme en
neuf points j'en retiens notamment que
chaque année il adressera un message à
la nation sur l'état de l'environnement
pour mesurer en quelque sorte la qualité
du cadre de vie des français pour les
projets d'équipement et d'aménagement
les plus importants on va mettre au
point une procédure d'audition publique
tout le monde pourra donc s'exprimer en
principe une agence de lutte contre la
pollution atmosphérique sera installé à
metz l'année prochaine un conseil de
l'information sur l'énergie
électro-nucléaire va être créé enfin une
charte de la qualité de la vie va être
élaboré en concertation avec les
associations
le terme écologie a été inventé par un
allemand et qu'elle en 1866 pour
désigner la science qui étudie les
rapports des êtres vivants avec le
milieu naturel mais aujourd'hui un
écologiste c'est d'abord un défenseur de
la nature et ce sont les dix dernières
années qui ont le plus transformer ce
mot philippe sainteny vous rappellera
les grandes étapes du passage de
l'écologie scientifique à l'écologie
politique
mais auparavant un court extrait de
l'allocution de monsieur giscard
d'estaing c'est une affaire sérieuse
thienpont une action sérieuse continue
et régionaux et il faudrait pas laisser
croire qu'il s'agit d'une mode qui
serait soumise à feu ne sais quelle
occupation de circonstance c'est en
réalité une des grandes attractions de
notre temps et l'authenticité des
grandes factions se mesurent dans une
certaine mesure par la permanence et la
constance des décisions qui sont prises
pour les accomplir il faut donc que la
politique de la qualité de la vie se
traduise dans les actes dans la vie
concrète g jour et qu'elle soit
ressentie comme une dimension de
l'action positive de notre temps
de grandes dates jalonnent cette prise
de conscience mars 1967
c'est le naufrage du torrey canyon et la
spectaculaire marée noire qui en résulte
puis la sphère de la vanoise où
s'affrontent protecteurs de la nature et
promoteur de stations de sports d'hiver
1972 à stockholm grande conférence des
nations unies sur l'environnement et
publication d'un rapport qui ferait
grand bruit
le rapport du club de rome halte à la
croissance
la même année création en france d'un
ministère spécialisé son premier
responsable robert poujade en 1974 aux
élections présidentielles l'agronome
rené dumont se présente il est le
premier candidat vert le score est
modeste mais par son intermédiaire
l'écologie pénètre pour la première fois
dans l'arène politique
le mouvement est lancé il culmine aux
récentes élections municipales des
candidats verts sont élus au premier
tour en alsace partout et notamment dans
la capitale des écologistes obtiennent
entre 10 et 14 % de voix enfin depuis
quelques temps déjà c'est la formidable
mobilisation de la plupart des militants
écologistes sur le front anti nucléaires
avec cet été l'affrontement meurtrier de
créer maleville parallèlement la presse
s'empare de cette préoccupation nouvelle
le premier en date de ces journaux c'est
la gueule ouverte créée par pierre
fournier l'écologie sans concession
suivront le sauvage et l'installation de
rubriques spécialisées dans les
quotidiens et les hebdomadaires à la
télévision la france défigurée et
toujours sur tf1 l'émission à la bonne
heure qui aborde régulièrement des
thèmes touchant à l'environnement et à
la sauvegarde du cadre de vie
le président de la république a
plusieurs fois manifesté son intérêt
pour l'écologie en 1972 il organise un
grand colloque à l'unesco sur le thème
économie et humanisme son objectif
tenter de préciser une nouvelle
philosophie de la croissance ils
s'opposent personnellement au projet de
voie express rive gauche à la
destruction de la cité fleurie il part
en guerre contre la multiplication des
tours dans la capitale et récemment à
l'occasion d'une visite dans le parc des
écrins
il s'intéresse au problème délicat de
l'écologie montagnat mais dans le même
temps il se crée dans l'autre pays
plusieurs dizaines d'associations de
défense de l'environnement
chaque mois des associations toujours
plus vigilante toujours plus exigeante
d'où l'intérêt de la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui
à propos d'environnement je voudrais
vous signaler second leg important d'une
propriété à l'état
le parfumeur jean pierre guerlain âgé de
80 ans vient de léguer en effet trois
mille hectares qu'il possède en loire
atlantique entre rezé-nantes et qui
constituent la majeure partie du lac de
grand lieu
c'est le plus grand lac privé de france
et jean pierre guerlain mais une
condition à ce legs et on l'applaudira
c'est que ce lac deviennent réserve
naturelle parce qu'il veut qu'on protège
à tout prix la flore et la faune tout à
fait exceptionnel qui y vit on y
dénombre plus de 250 espèces nicheuses
et les hérons du lac de grand-lieu sont
les plus célèbres d'europe
c'est plus qu'un beau geste à mon avis
et puis j'ai fait une énorme bêtise tout
à l'heure qui portent préjudice à un
journal au profit d'un autre
je vous ai dit qu'un sondage sofres
figaro faisait état d'une montée dans
les dents de la cote de raymond barre et
d'une montée encore plus forte de la
cote de monsieur giscard d'estaing et
bien pas du tout c'est pas dans le
figaro et c'est pas la sofres c'est dans
france soir et c'est un sondage ifop
voyez comme on est distrait parfois hier
soir la police a investi l'hôtel bel air
à rhisnes il à knonau zh en plaine
champagne pouilleuse un hôtel réservé à
des curistes du jeune et pourquoi
à cause de deux décès celui d'un homme
de 65 ans mort en septembre dernier à
l'hôpital de troyes
après une cure au bel-air il pesait 38
kg puis celui d'un homme de 25 ans en
mai dernier à londres
il revenait d'un séjour au bel-air et il
pesait 29 kg les policiers se sont
souvenu d'un 3e cas plus anciens la mort
d'un homme de 25 ans qui avait valu aux
directeurs d'établissements d'ailleurs
une condamnation et une fermeture de
l'établissement pour dix mois la
technique de ce régime est connue jeunes
absolue et simplement de l'eau la
motivation principale dans ce cas
semble-t-il des patients de l'hôtel bel
air était l'angoissent la dépression et
non pas comme on l'a dit la cure
d'amaigrissement coûts du régime dit
sous surveillance médicale
70 à 120 francs par jour deux hommes
sont maintenant en cause
albert mauceri le directeur qui dit
d'avoir pris qui doit avoir appris aux
indes les vertus du jeune et le docteur
courrier le médecin de la maison
a priori son profil ne milite pas pour
une surveillance du jeune qui en
d'autres circonstances d'ailleurs je
puis en témoigner à donner des résultats
plus qu'intéressant il faut se garder de
condamner quelque chose qu'on ne connaît
pas à travers ce fait divers
voici les témoignages recueillis hier au
moment de l'évacuation d'établissement
du directeur et du médecin inculpé ce
soir tous les deux d'homicide
involontaire d'exercice illégal de la
médecine et d'omission de porter secours
jean consulter les soins que vous
apportiez aux curistes moi je ne porte
aucun soin aux curistes sont des gens
qui viennent qu'ils veulent de leur
propre gré faire une cure de jeunes et
sont visités à l'arrivée à faire un
médecin passe pratiquement quatre ou
cinq fois par semaine ils sont visités à
la sortie et voilà quel genre de soins
vous donniez au curry a aucun moi je les
examiner
on leur donne immédiatement ni joie ni
rien du tout ni vin ni plus fort ni
aucun médicament il faut une cure
l'alimentation alors vous médecin quel
était votre rôle et mon rôle c'était de
venir ici quand on m'appelle doit
examiner les personnes qui étaient là de
lui dire allez vous-en et rentrer chez
vous ou bien vous pouvez rester ici
pendant quelques jours qu'un régime
végétarien leur donner des conseils sur
leur alimentation
là bas c'est monsieur nô thriller
devenus les conseils celui diététiciens
jeune homme qui est parti le premier il
est parti en angleterre par ses propres
moyens
toiture sera il est mort pesant 29 kg
quand même c'est pas beaucoup je ne sais
pas dans quelles conditions éléments je
viens de l'apprendre je ne savais pas du
tout est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'être un peu responsables de ce qui
arrive à remplir absolument pas il est
parti en bon état voilà dans tous les
cas attention aux inconscients ou
charlatan avoue jean claude narcy pour
les autres nouvelles de ce journal
c'était la deuxième journée aujourd'hui
du maréchal tito à paris avec un dépôt
de gerbe ce matin l'arc de triomphe en
compagnie d'yvon bourges le ministre des
armées
demain les deux chefs d'état français et
bulgares adresse s'adresseront à la
presse et ce soit une grande réception a
lieu dans la galerie des glaces à
versailles avec 4000 invités cet
après-midi tête à tête avec valéry
giscard d'estaing sur le thème de la
détente est ouest le maréchal tito a
donné certaines informations au
président de la république sur son
récent voyage en chine ce pays d'après
lui connaître un bouleversement complet
enfin le conflit sino soviétique lui
apparaît pour leur irrémédiable
le premier ministre espagnol a réuni
aujourd'hui tous les partis politiques
pour un second sommet au cours duquel
les 31 participants ont commencé à
étudier le programme de réformes
politiques de la société espagnole
préparait pour le gouvernement
entre autres mesures d'exception mesures
pour faciliter la lutte contre le
terrorisme des mesures déception la
suspension des écoutes téléphoniques et
le renforcement des droits de la femme
béatrice à yann des filles du président
chilien a tué au cou du coup au cours du
mois du coup d'état militaire qui le
renversa en 73 s'est suicidé hier dans
sa maison de la havane
béatrice ayant des était dans un état
dépressif le fioul domestique va
augmenter de 2,7 centimes par litre à
compter de demain le comité des prix a
autorisé cette hausse de 3 et demi pour
cent qui est destiné à répercuter la
hausse de 5% des prix du brut
mises en vigueur par l'arabie saoudite
et les émirats arabes et milieux
pétroliers ne sont pas satisfaits de
cette mesure qu'ils jugent insuffisante
la dernière augmentation pour le fioul
domestique remonte au mois de février
dernier
la cgt est descendu dans la rue dans les
rues de paris pour la défense de
l'emploi
des défilés ont été organisés en
plusieurs points de la capitale des
délégations se sont rendus au siège du
cnpf et à l'hôtel matignon
enfin un meeting a clos cette journée
andré bergeron qui sera reçu au début du
mois par le président de la république
et par le premier ministre aura
l'occasion de demander à ses
interlocuteurs une cinquième semaine de
congés payés pour les salariés les
dirigeants de force ouvrière pense que
cette cinquième semaine ne
s'ajouteraient pas aux congés d'été et
qu'elles seraient prises en hiver les
dirigeants de monter fibres de saint
nabor ont 48 heures pour payer les
salaires de septembre à leurs employés
c'est le délai fixé par le gouvernement
français l'hebdomadaire du parti
socialiste l'unité paraît cette semaine
sous une nouvelle formule vous voyez la
couleur la couverture est en couleur la
présentation est plus aérée et il ya
également intérieur davantage de
publicité un boeing 737 de la lufthansa
a été détourné avec 86 passagers à bord
et cinq membres d'équipage un pirate de
l'air qui se fait appeler capitaine
walter mohamed a obligé le commandant de
bord qui effectue la liaison palma
francfort a détourné d'abord sur rome
pour faire le plein et ensuite en
direction de l'aéroport de larnaca dans
la zone grecque de chypre
le pirate a demandé la libération de
tous les prisonniers politiques d'un
mise
le groupe des jays qui seraient détenues
en république fédérale allemande et les
autorités allemandes n'ont pas
connaissance de ce groupe et pense pour
l'instant qu'il n'y a aucun rapport
entre les détournements et l'enlèvement
du patron des patrons allemand monsieur
hans martin schleyer l'avion est attendu
dans quelques instants près de nicosie
donc à larnaca et les pirates je
l'apprends par cette dépêche de l afp
les pirates deviennent d'informer
l'aéroport de leurs intentions
d'atterrir parmi les trois lauréats du
prix nobel de médecine
un grand médecin au nom bien français
roger gym il a quitté la france en 1950
estimant ne pas avoir les moyens
nécessaires pour poursuivre ses travaux
qui portent essentiellement sur la
découverte de découverte d'hormones
secrétée par une partie du cerveau
l'hypophyse ces travaux sont renouvelées
ont renouvelé nos connaissances sur le
fonctionnement des glandes à secret sion
interne qui joue un rôle capital en
particulier dans la vie génital de la
femme
notre président monsieur jean cazeneuve
a signé avec le président de la
télévision nationale korean monsieur
onkyo mots un accord dans lequel sont
associés du côté français tf1 et
l'institut national audiovisuel la
télévision nationale de la corée du sud
se proposait changer les actualités avec
notre chaîne et s'intéresse vivement
possibilité de diffuser sur ses antennes
des programmes français qui semble de
plus en plus apprécié des
téléspectateurs d'extrême orient
l'attentât contre la préfecture de
quimper a été revendiqué par le flb lé
front de libération de la bretagne cet
attentat je le rappelle a fait pour un
million de dégâts en football hier soir
à l'angleterre jouer au luxembourg pour
la qualification en coupe du monde
les deux bus vous allez voir sur votre
écran ont été réussis par kennedy et
marine air mais ils ne suffiront pas
pour les britanniques afin qu'ils
obtiennent le visa pour l'argentine il
faut se rappeler que l'urss et déjà
éliminés que la france doit battre
impérativement la bulgarie le 16
novembre prochain et que la belgique se
trouve dans une position difficile
la yougoslavie aura du mal elles aussi
obtenir sa qualification en revanche le
brésil trois fois vainqueur est d'ores
et déjà qualifie enfin pour gagner le
tiercé il fallait jouer le 5 le 3 et le
2 ils rapportent dans l'ordre pour 5
francs
6900 et front à 50 dans un ordre
différent 992 3 le temps en début
d'après midi les températures étaient
restées basses dans l'est et le centre
est mais sur le reste de la france
elles étaient en hausse demain matin le
temps sera frais il y aura des
brouillards principalement de
l'aquitaine au nord est
ensuite eh bien le soleil brillera comme
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du pays
seuls quelques nuages passagers seront
observées dans l'ouest les températures
maximales seront en hausse
voilà je vous avais promis on vous avait
promis dans les titres un reportage sur
le piccolo teatro de milan qui va fêter
ses son 30e anniversaire à paris c'est
un très beau théâtre il faut aller le
voir à l'odéon-théâtre de france eh bien
écoutez ce reportage n'ont plus le temps
de diffuser je vous le promet pour
demain sur bonne soirée à tous au nom de
toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité le
dernier journal eh bien je vais vous le
dire tout de suite avec jean pierre
pernaut vers 23h25 merci